[Musik]
nach den krawallen in berlin die politik
diskutiert über ein sicherheitskonzept
für den reichstag
viele fragen im wirecard skandal ein
untersuchungsausschuss im bundestag
zeichnet sich immer deutlicher ab
sommerbilanz 2020 auch in diesem jahr
viel insgesamt zu wenig regen und es war
zu warm
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am montag der sport
kommt heute von norbert lehmann ein
stück ohne haben doch von mir das was
sich bei den demonstrationen gegen die
korona maßnahmen am wochenende in berlin
abspielte war auch heute noch das
beherrschende thema im land wie konnte
es passieren dass nur drei polizisten
den bundestag gegen anstürmende
rechtsextreme verteidigen mussten und
welche lehren müssen aus den vorfällen
gezogen werden noch mal die fakten zur
erinnerung gegen 19 uhr zieht die
polizei ihre einsatzkräfte an der
südseite des reichstagsgebäudes zusammen
weil dort viele demonstranten unterwegs
sind
in diesem moment ruft eine rednerin auf
einer bühne im nordwesten dazu auf die
absperrung zu überwinden und die stufen
zu besetzen
mehr als 300 menschen stürmen richtung
eingang viele gehören der reichs bürger
szene an
einige tragen die schwarz weiß roten
flagge des kaiserreichs über die
reaktionen auf diese szenen berichtet
thomas reichert am montag der nach
sitzen drei berliner polizisten beim
bundespräsidenten jene drei die sich
alleine auf den stufen des reichstags
den anstürmenden entgegenstellten
das sind bilder von einem rechten
aktivisten der impuls die absperrgitter
durchbrach schwarz weiß rote reichs
flecken sind zu sehen symbol der
rechtsextremen
sie zeigen die nähe zu jenen die am
selben ort deutschlands gäste demokratie
die weimarer republik bekämpften das ist
nicht nur verabscheuungswürdig sondern
angesichts der geschichte dieses ortes
geradezu unerträglich wir dulden keine
antidemokratische hetze und keine
herabwürdigung der bundesrepublik
deutschland im bundestag
wie aber konnte es dazu kommen dass
rechtsextreme kübler und gewalttäter
sich vor dem parlament breit machen
konnten
der bundestags-vizepräsident kritisiert
die polizeistrategie
die tatsache dass 300 menschen die
reichsstädte haben erreichen können
deutet darauf hin dass die ankündigung
in sozialen medien nicht ernst genommen
worden sind denn es vielfältig
aufgerufen worden die demonstration zu
nutzen um den reichstag zu stürmen
doch berlins zuständige innensenator
erklärt heute eigentlich alles richtig
gemacht zu haben das ist nicht so dass
der deutsche bundestag schutzlos gewesen
dass dort stand polizei deren linien ist
durchbrochen worden
dann standen drei polizisten auf den
stufen des reichstages und kurz danach
kam die entsprechenden entlassen kräften
durch die bilder vom samstag wecken
zweifel
zu sehen ist auch dass viele die
angeblich gegen korona maßnahmen
protestieren wollten sich nicht von den
rechtsextremen distanzierten
natürlich ist es im rahmen der
meinungsfreiheit dass man auch gegen
korona maßnahmen demonstrieren kann und
dennoch muss man natürlich ganz genau
schauen wer ruft zu dieser demonstration
auf was wird da angekündigt der schock
über den tabubruch sitzt tief was nun
beginnt ist eine debatte darüber ob die
demokratie zu nachlässig war gegenüber
ihren feinden und theo koll war die
demokratie zu nachlässig gegenüber ihren
feinden
nein ich glaube das kann man so
allgemein nicht sagen aber in diesem
konkreten fall haben offensichtlich
polizeiführung und berliner senat die
bedeutung von bildern unterschätzt sie
haben zugelassen dass das herz der
demokratie so jedenfalls nannte der
bundespräsident heute das parlament
missbraucht wurde
im guten ist die zugänglichkeit zum
parlamentsgebäude hier ein wichtiger
teil politischer bürgernähe nicht
umsonst hat das parlament eine
glaskuppel aus dem man der politik bei
der arbeit zusehen kann missbrauch aber
verknüpfen sich dann nazi flaggen denn
die reichs flaggen wurden jahrelang von
den nazis auch benutzt mit dem bild des
deutschen bundestages und werden quasi
überhöht durch den ort und durch seine
historischen hintergrund wenn man sich
die heftige reaktion heute anschaut dann
war diese nachlässigkeit aber eher ein
alarmierender ausreißer vielen dank für
die einordnung tier und zu diesem thema
haben wir weitere informationen für sie
zusammengestellt in der zdf- heute- app
finden sie unter anderem
eine analyse wie es zu der eskalation am
bundestag gekommen ist und jetzt der
blick auf die korona zahlen in
deutschland im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage wurden täglich 1260
neuinfektionen gemeldet gestern waren es
1280 eine maßnahme des virus einzudämmen
ist eine masken pflicht aber man soll
sie gelten und wo gerade für schulen
wird das immer wieder diskutiert und in
den bundesländern unterschiedlich
gehandhabt heute gab es für nordrhein
westfalen und bayern neue regelungen
noten leinhos berichtet es sind die
reiserückkehrer die in bayern sorgen
machen denn sie bescheren dem freistaat
derzeit die höchsten infektionszahlen
bundesweit damit dass nach ferienende
nächste woche nicht reihenweise zu
schulschließungen führt gibt es nun die
masken pflicht im unterricht wir glauben
dass das unter dem strich die beste
möglichkeit ist einen schulstart zu
ermöglichen das infektionsrisiko aus dem
urlaub in der weiterverbreitung so
gering wie möglich zu halten aber
gleichzeitig mit einem effektiven
schulstart zu beginnen bayern folgt
damit der strategie von
nordrhein-westfalen als dort die schule
vor drei wochen wieder anfing gab es
ebenfalls steigende corona zahlen und
die regierung verhängte eine masken
pflicht im unterricht bis heute wir
liegen mit den am infektionszahlen im
statistisch durchschnittlichen
infektionsgeschehen und deswegen haben
wir auch entschieden diese masken
pflicht nicht zu verlängern
die positive bilanz der ministerin an
keiner schule sei es zu einem
unkontrollierten ausbruch gekommen
schüler in nrw können ihre masken ab
morgen im unterricht abnehmen damit hat
bayern von nun an bundesweit eine
sonderrolle eine landesweite masken
pflicht im unterricht gibt es nur noch
hier
die große mehrheit der länder schreibt
masken nur außerhalb der klassenräume
vor
in den gängen treppenhäusern auf den
toiletten keine umfassende masken
pflicht haben sachsen sachsen-anhalt und
thüringen
eine gemeinsamkeit gibt es allerdings
grundschüler sind so gut wie überall von
der masken pflicht ausgenommen die linke
sucht neue parteichefs bzw chefinnen
die bisherigen vorsitzenden katja
kipping und bernd riexinger treten ab
die anforderungen an die neuen sind klar
sie sollen ein auseinanderdriften der
flügel verhindern und die linke in die
nächste bundesregierung führen
denn in der hauptstadt sei die zeit für
so wörtlich rebellisches regieren
gekommen wie die noch-vorsitzende
kipping heute sagte christiane hübscher
berichtet sie gehen weil ihre satzung
das so vorsieht kein parteiamt der
linken darf länger als acht jahre
ausgeübt werden katja kipping und bernd
riexinger scheinen mit ihrem abschied
versöhnt ich bin keinesfalls irgendwie
amtsmüde und bin auch gar nicht
gezwungen worden von der partei jetzt
aufzuhören sondern es hat viel mit
persönlicher lebensplanung zu tun hat
aber auch viel damit zu tun dass jetzt
der richtige zeitpunkt gekommen ist für
einen stabwechsel als wir
parteivorsitzende wurden bestand die
linke faktisch aus zwei parteien die
irgendwie zusammen geklammert waren und
es ist in den letzten jahren gelungen
dass die linke sich aus sich heraus
weiterentwickelt zu einer
gesamtdeutschen partei als die ostfrau
in der westmann 2012 auf dem göttinger
parteitag per kampfabstimmung gewählt
wurden drohte der linken noch die
spaltung
heute stellen sich der partei neue
fragen soll sie rot-rot-grün auch im
bund anstreben
die scheidende parteichef in dringend
dazu dass wir nicht nur meckern sondern
dass wir auch wirklich machen den gestus
von regierenden bewegungen rebellischen
regieren auch im bund zu wagen für die
nachfolge wird eine weibliche
doppelspitze diskutiert aus der
hessischen fraktionschefin janine
wissler und der thüringerinnen susanne
hennig welt die mit dem blumenstrauß
wurf von erfurt bekannt wurde
doch auch andere könnten ihre kandidatur
in kürze erklären
wir sind für viele konstellationen reif
aber ich rate dazu nicht zuallererst
über das personal zu reden sondern in
den parteitag vor allen dingen so zu
gehen dass wir alte gräben überwinden
wie es für kipping und riexinger
politisch weitergehen könnte
das wollten beide heute nicht verraten
zum fall wirecard im finanzausschuss
sprach heute die opposition von
multiplem staatsversagen
die rolle der aufsichtsbehörden und des
kanzleramts rund um den bilanzskandal
müsse genau geklärt werden
der zahlungsdienstleister wirecard galt
als vorzeigeunternehmen der börsenwert
wuchs rasant 2018 folgte der aufstieg in
den dax dann erste zweifel und der
verdacht auf vorgetäuschte gewinne und
manipulierte bilanzen der schaden für
banken und investoren könnte sich auf
3,2 milliarden euro belaufen
aus berlin andreas kühner ist der mann
der merkels wirtschaftspolitik projekt
geht kameras am liebsten aus dem weg
interviews gibt er nie heute sitzt lars
hendrik röller im finanzausschuss und
muss merkels einsatz für wirecard
erklären vor allem in china roller saß
daneben als merkel in peking für
wirecard färbt das war vor einem jahr
nur wenige tage nach einem diskreten
treffen nach einem besuch von ex
minister guttenberg im kanzleramt der
als berater für wirecard tätig war
sie hat exakt in china das gemacht was
er von ihr erbeten hatte
und da war auch wenig zeit vor der
abreise noch zu prüfen was dann an
wirecard vielleicht zu beachten wäre für
das gute gespräch dankt guttenberg
merkel schriftlich an herrn roller sende
ich gesondert eine notiz köhler und
merkel hätten in china die ersten
betrugsvorwürfe kennen müssen sagt die
opposition die cdu widerspricht da gab
es auch keine hinweise oder keine
warnungen durch das finanzministerium
was ja noch mal extra vorher angefragt
wurde
insofern ist es folgerichtig dass sich
die bundesregierung auch im ausland für
deutsche unternehmen um deutsche
interessen stark macht eines der größten
wirecard rätsel ist die flucht des
spitzenmanagers jan marschalek für die
opposition sucht die regierung nicht
entschieden genug
warum konnte er massa lag ausreisen und
warum hängen wir fahndungsplakate wenn
es auf der anderen seite berichte gibt
er sei in russland wenn das so ist ich
kann das selber natürlich nicht
beantworten
dann müsste es ja nicht fahndungsplakate
sondern auslieferungsanträge geben der
mann hinter merkel vor kameras hat er
auch heute nichts gesagt und im
ausschuss nur wenig bei der
parlamentswahl in montenegro ist die
prowestliche partei von präsident
janukowitsch mit rund 35 prozent
stärkste kraft geworden
sie verfehlte mit ihren bündnispartnern
aber die mehrheit und muss sich darauf
einstellen nach fast 30 jahren die macht
zu verlieren
stattdessen könnte ein
oppositionsbündnis die regierungsbildung
schaffen dessen stärkste kraft will das
nato-mitglied montenegro wieder näher an
russland und serbien heranführen und nun
nach polen
dort haben die menschen an die vorboten
des politischen umbruchs im land vor
genau 40 jahren erinnert 1980
erschütterten arbeiter streiks das
kommunistische regime im danziger
abkommen willigte die staatsführung
schließlich in die gründung der
solidarischen der ersten unabhängigen
gewerkschaft im damaligen ostblock
inzwischen sind die reformer von damals
tief zerstritten
natalie steger der held von damals am
entscheidenden ort von damals an der
danziger werft doch vertreter der
nationalkonservativen stadtspitze sind
nicht an seiner seite
valencia ist scharfer kritiker der
regierung sieht die rechtsstaatlichkeit
in polen in gefahr
eine aufgabe ist meiner meinung nach
wie man mit demagogie populismus und
lügen der politiker zurechtkommt
gleicher ort aber mit zeitlichem abstand
die staatliche zeremonie das bedürfnis
nach freiheit und würde war so stark
dass es nicht zu stoppen war sommer 1980
tagelanger streik in der lenin-werft
gegen das kommunistische system
ihr anführer der elektriker lech walesa
der 31 august wird die geburtsstunde der
solidarnosc es folgen rückschläge doch
der lauf der geschichte ist nicht mehr
aufzuhalten
nach der politischen wende wird der held
der solidarnosc 1990 staatspräsident er
unterstützt einen harten reformkurs aus
kameraden werden feinde die
kaczynski-zwillinge brechen bald mit
vanessa was bis heute nachwirkt das
milde solidarnost hat sich 89 90 geteilt
heute versucht ein teil die geschichte
neu zu schreiben war winzer zu streichen
den sie nicht anerkennen
das ist das erbe des konfliktes zwischen
den kaczynski brüder und löschwasser die
gewerkschaft solidarnosc steht heute der
national-konservativen regierungspartei
peace now
viele sind mittlerweile ausgetreten auch
lech walesa dauerregen hat in den
alpenregionen in österreich und italien
schwere schäden verursacht bei bozen
musste wegen eines erdrutsches die
brenner autobahn komplett gesperrt
werden
in klausen trat der saab über die ufer
die bewohner wurden aufgerufen ihre
häuser zu verlassen
im zillertal in österreich zerstörte ein
herabstürzender fels eine
materialseilbahn menschen kamen nicht zu
schaden
in deutschland war der sommer 2020 so
oder so eine rede thema hitze
trockenheit sturz regen blitz und donner
je nach region war alles im angebot
und dieser sommer hat gezeigt worauf wir
uns einstellen müssen in zeiten des
klimawandels dass ausreichend wasser
etwa nicht mehr so selbstverständlich
ist wie früher
stefan schlosser zieht bilanz die
wasseraufbereitungsanlage in die
das heim am rhein über 30 millionen
kubikmeter wasser werden jedes jahr aus
dem fluss gepumpt und gereinigt um es
anschließend auf feldern versickern zu
lassen
so lässt sich ein allzu starkes absinken
des grundwasserspiegels verhindern und
die trinkwasserversorgung der region
sicherstellen
ist diese anlage hier besonders wichtig
sie bildet den regen nach das ist
eigentlich eine regel maschine
das heißt alles das was der regen an
grundwasserneubildung licht bringen
können wir durch diese anlage nachbilden
zu warm und zu trocken das gilt auch für
den sommer 2020 im schnitt 1,9 grad lag
die temperatur über dem langjährigen
mittel
juni und juli noch normal der august
brachte die große hitze höchsttemperatur
in diesem jahr trier mit 38,7 grad
regional gab es deutliche unterschiede
auch wenn langanhaltende
hochsommerlicher farben eher rar waren
machten hitze und trockenheit vielerorts
der natur zu schaffen starke unwetter
mit überschwemmungen dagegen zum
beispiel in südbayern
grundsätzlich gehen wir davon aus dass
es gerade in den sommermonaten trockner
wird dass der niederschlag sich vor
allen dingen auf schauer und gewitter
konzentrieren wird so dass eben das
immer nur regionale auswirkungen hat
lang anhaltenden niederschlags perioden
die werden durch den klimawandel eher
abnehmen
dieser sommer war nicht ganz so extrem
wie die vorjahre gehört aber zu den zehn
wärmsten je gemessenen und unsere die
arbeit ja das erste tennis grand slam
turnier seit beginn der pandemie
viele topstars haben ihre teilnahme eben
wegen krone abgesagt deutschlands beste
tennisspielerin angelique kerber ist
allerdings dabei und gleich eine runde
weiter mit maske ins leere stadion das
erste match seit januar kann für
angelique kerber kam ungewöhnlicher
seien gegen galia tomljanovic aus
australien gewinnt sie den ersten satz
mit mühe 6 zu 4
im auftaktmatch der 140 us open sind die
ballwechsel meist lang die vorhand von
kerber immer wieder entscheidend 2016
hat sie hier in new york gewonnen
torben beltz ihr trainer von damals bis
neuerdings wieder dabei
erst kurzfristig hatte sich kerber zur
teilnahme entschieden mit 6 zu 4 und 6
zu 4 gewinnt sie ihr comeback match in
corona jahr nach der längsten pause
ihrer karriere zu tode fonds heute die
dritte etappe 198 kilometer von nizza
nach system und die gewann der
australier caliban im massensprint vor
dem iren sam bennett und dem italiener
giacomo nizzolo die deutschen fahrer
spielten bei der zweiten sprint ankunft
erneut keine rolle
das gelbe trikot des gesamtersten trägt
weiterhin der französische superstar
julia verliebt
sie wollten es doch den männern des fc
bayern nach machen und das triple holen
das highlight der saison durch einen
sieg im champions league finale
doch die starken frauen aus wolfsburg
scheiterten gestern am tann noch
stärkeren frauen aus leo sie wollten die
krone und gingen enttäuscht wieder
geschlagen von den lehrerinnen die von
beginn an dominierten schon das 0 1 war
der eigenen nervosität geschuldet und
auch das 0 2 zeigte wolfsburg die
grenzen auf trotz einer kämpferischen
zweiten halbzeit mehr als dieser
anschlusstreffer sollte nicht gelingen
alexandra popp mit köpfchen zum 126
wolfsburgerin genutzt dort hier machte
dann alles klar für lyon traf in der 88
minute zum 3 2 1 wie die mannschaft
zurückgekommen ist das macht mich sehr
stolz
aber die enttäuschung ist sehr groß eine
deutsche nationalspielerin konnte
allerdings feiern dzsenifer marozsán
gewandete long zum vierten mal
nacheinander die champions league und
ich war das fünfte mal hintereinander
dass die frauen aus lyon
die champions league gewonnen tolle
leistungen in zeiten von corona ist
vieles anders so auch bei einer ersten
großen live gala in den usa den mtv
music awards in new york alles im freien
auf mehreren bühnen verteilt im fokus
eine frau die gleich fünfmal ab räumte
lady gaga
hier stellt man zur massen pflicht seid
freundlich fragt masken und seid mutig
rief lady gaga wie bei jedem ihrer
auftritte einen anderen mund nasenschutz
trug sozusagen als schickes accessoire
tanzen und singen mit maske auch eine
ziemlich sportliche leistung zum wetter
da sind morgen wieder schauer und
gewitter im programm die details dazu
hat gleich ist intelli das war es von
uns danke für ihr interesse
das heute journal mit marietta slomka um
drei viertel 10 und wir sind morgen um 7
wieder für sie da haben sie noch einen
schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter weiterer regen
folgt in der kommenden nacht und morgen
im tagesverlauf das sehen wir hier auf
unserem film und da sehen wir es nachts
sind jährigen wolken unterwegs im süden
auch dann tagsüber und nach norden hin
einzelne schauer das schauen wir uns mal
genauer an in der nacht also teilweise
kompakte wolken mit regen teils auch mit
schauern
nach norden hin ist es eher trocken mit
temperaturen von sieben grad richtung
ems und 13 grad im rhein-main-gebiet
morgen im tagesverlauf lockern die
schauer und gewitter wieder auf vor
allem nach süden hin
da wird es kräftiger regnen nach norden
ist es eher trocken und da scheint die
sonne temperaturen dazu erreichen
höchstwerte um 21 grad im osten und 14
grad an den alpen zum beispiel das ist
die temperaturspanne die nächsten tage
bringen uns einzelne schauer zb im
norden deutschlands 15 bis 21 grad am
mittwoch ab donnerstag dreht allmählich
der wind auf südwest und freitag
bekommen wir dann wieder neue wärme mit
werten bis 27 grad
ein schöner abend